auch nach einigen jahren noch gedacht
werden soll und man hat sich für diesen
tag entschieden weil die europäische
union schon seit 2005 an diesem tag der
opfer von terrorismus gedenkt warum der
elfte märz am 11 märz 2004 verübten
damals islamistische terroristen in
madrid
bombenanschläge sie werden sich erinnern
fast 200 menschen wurden dabei getötet
und hunderte verletzt zu dieser
einführung dieses nationalen gedenktages
spricht nun als erstes
bundesinnenministeriums herr präsident
in meine damen und herren in diesem jahr
haben wir den ersten nationalen
gedenktag für die opfer terroristischer
gewalt begangen mein dank gilt an dieser
stelle auch dem opfer beauftragten der
bundesregierung herrn kuba vor wenigen
wochen hat das bundeskabinett
beschlossen diesen gedenktag das elfter
märz zu beginn der elfte märz ist damit
ein tag der erinnerung des mitgefühls
aber auch der mahnung mit aller
entschlossenheit gegen terroristische
bedrohungen in unserem land vorzugehen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
unsere welt steht seither kopf das sind
alle coaches worte zwei jahre nach dem
rassistischen anschlag in hanau bei dem
ihr bruder hamza getötet wurde er wurde
22 jahre als
da ist nach wie vor ein ganz großer riss
in meinem leben sagt astrid passieren
die ihren vater bei dem islamistischen
anschlag auf dem breitscheidplatz
2016 verlor es vergehe kein tag an dem
sie nicht voll schmerz an jeden verlust
denken an den terroranschlag der ihre
angehörigen aus dem leben gerissen hat
das sagen einer kultur witsch und astrid
passieren sie machen das durch was alle
mütter väter söhne töchter was partner
verwandte oder freunde durch leiden wenn
ein terroranschlag das leben ihrer
liebsten auslöst die völlige
schockstarre die fassungslosigkeit das
nicht glauben können der schmerz der nie
vergeht
viel zu oft stehen nach einem anschlag
aber die täter im vordergrund
es geht um die motive mit dem gedenktag
für die opfer terroristischer gewalt
wollen wir jetzt die aufmerksamkeit auf
das schicksal der opfer und ihrer
angehörigen richten und das ist so
entscheidend in hanau haben es die
angehörigen unter dem motto
james benannt und das ist etwas das wir
das schicksal das uns allen in wir
wollen damit dass das schicksal der in
unserer gesellschaft
auch bewusst bleibt und erhalten bleibt
und die uns daran erinnern viele kämpfen
sich dabei mit großer kraft zurück ins
leben wir dürfen sie aber dabei als
stadt nicht alleine lassen ich möchte
dass die betroffenen und ihre familie
mit viel mehr empathie und sensibilität
unterstützt werden von allen staatlichen
stellen
der linksextremistischen terror der
roten armee fraktion der bewegung
zweiter juni und der revolutionären
zellen der vor allem in den 70er und
80er jahren für angst und schrecken
sorgte es nicht vergessen diese
attentate wirken bis heute nach und
lassen den hinterbliebenen keine ruhe
die bedrohung durch den islamistischen
terrorismus hält unverändert an
trauriges zeugnis sind der handschlag am
breitscheidplatz sowie die
messerangriffe in dresden in hamburg
oder hannover
wir ihnen an den anschlag bei musik
festival in ansbach den anschlag auf der
berliner autobahn im zug bei würzburg
oder der brandanschlag in waldkraiburg
der anschlag auf einen sikh tempel in
essen und am flughafen in frankfurt und
eine spur des rechten terrors zieht sich
durch unsere jüngere geschichte
hoyerswerda
rostock mölln solingen der terror des
nsu der anschlag am münchner olympia
einkaufszentrum der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten dr walter lübke
der terror von halle und hanau
auch das nunmehr über 40 jahre lang
zurückliegende attentat auf das münchner
oktoberfest bewegt noch immer die opfer
und deren angehörige es ist die höchste
pflicht des staates seine bürgerinnen
und bürger zu schützen aber kein staat
kann völlige sicherheit garantieren wenn
es trotz aller präventiven maßnahmen
doch zu einem terroranschlag kommt muss
der staat dafür sorgen dass den
betroffenen schnell wirksam geholfen
wird konkret entwickelt zb das
bundeskriminalamt gemeinsam mit den
ländern gerade die strategische
zusammenarbeit weiter und baut ein
spezielles netzwerk zur opfer fürsorge
auf es ist mir ein großes anliegen das
von terrorismus betroffene nicht allein
gelassen werden wir müssen ihre
interessen und rechte verteidigen und
stärken jeder einzelne mensch zählt
vielen dank
ich gebe dem kollegen michael breilmann
das wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen terroropfern
ist in deutschland ein neuer gedenktag
gewidmet worden und das ist gut und
richtig so terror ist eine bedrohung
einer bedrohung die europa ja die ganze
welt betrifft und es ist daher gut den
elften märz 2004 als
al-qaida-terroristen bomben in zügen den
madrid zündeten 191 menschen töteten
sowie fast 2000 verletzten dass dieser
europäische gedenktag nun auch die
menschen in deutschland mit einschließt
neben der trauer über
das leid spüren wir gerade anlässlich
solcher taten dass uns das geschehene
oft die sicherheit des alltags zu nehmen
droht dennoch und gerade deswegen müssen
wir uns dem terror auch in zukunft mit
vereinten kräften entgegen stellen denn
es geht uns vor allem auch um unsere
werte und diese werte die lassen wir uns
von niemandem nehmen erst recht nicht
von hinterhältigen terroristen oder
feigen fördern unsere werte des
grundgesetzes sie sind und verhandeln
und vertretbar
gilt
was gerade auch oft über die menschen in
der ukraine gesagt wird die derzeit
brutaler gewalt in einem abscheulichen
krieg ausgesetzt sind dass sie
stellvertretend für uns alle getroffen
wurden und ja es war terroranschläge
sind anschläge auf unser zusammenleben
auf unsere werte und unsere freiheit
alle terrorattacken wir hätten auch bis
heute nach und lassen den betroffenen
und auch deren familien keine ruhe und
unser gemeinwesen steht den betroffenen
gegenüber daher schon in einer
besonderen verantwortung und schuldet
ihnen eine transparente aufklärung der
tat ich
opfer familien wollen verstehen wollen
entschuldigung wollen aufmerksamkeit und
konsequenzen sie wollen schlicht
gerechtigkeit und die haben sie auch
verdient opfer erster oder zweiter
klasse darf es dabei nicht geben und es
darf keine rolle spielen ob die tat im
innere ausland geschickt unser staat
muss den bürgerinnen und bürgern hierbei
stehe und daher sagen ja auch dem opfer
beauftragten der bundesregierung dem
kollegen kuba unterstützung zu wenn er
einen sensibleren umgang mit opfern von
terroranschlägen anmahnt ja die
psychische betreuung ist auch etwas wo
wir noch besser werden denn das leiden
der menschen ist nicht deren privatsache
sondern es ist angelegenheit von uns
alle und für uns
steht neben der betreuung und gedenken
der opfer natürlich immer auch die frage
im mittelpunkt wie können wir weitere
terroranschläge wie können wir weitere
opfer verhindern und der kampf gegen den
terror beginnen nämlich überall dort wo
wir hass und diskriminierung erleben
gewalttaten sind oft das ende eines
radikalisierungsprozess und terroristen
dürfen niemals das gefühl bekommen
beifall für ihre taten erhalten zu
können starres gedenken alleine wird
aber nicht reichen wir müssen unsere
sicherheitsbehörden daher auch in
zukunft alle möglichen in die hand geben
um terroranschläge und taten im vorfeld
zu verhindern und um am besten fall auch
keine neuen opfer beklagen zu müssen an
dieser stelle ist million heute aber
auch ganz besonders wichtig
auszusprechen einen großen dank an alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern der
sicherheitsbehörden die tag und nacht
für unsere sicherheit arbeiten und auch
das
und auch das hört in diesem zusammenhang
erwähnt wir brauchen in der politik aber
auch in der gesellschaft eine haltung
gegenüber den mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern vom verfassungsschutz und
vom polizei die von wertschätzung
vertrauen und von respekt geprägt ist
und auch in der heutigen debatte
müssen wir fragen wie wir als politik
den sicherheitsbehörden helfen können
ihren job auch in der terrorbekämpfung
zu machen und sie gerade nicht aus einem
grundsätzlichen misstrauen herauszugehen
und ihre möglichkeiten einzuschränken
dazu gehört im übrigen auch eine
ideologiefreie haltung die probleme im
übrigen nicht verschweigt was mir heute
aber auch ganz besonders wichtig ist zu
betonen ohne die konkrete unterstützung
auch von den bürgerinnen und bürgern den
alltäglichen entgegentreten von
rassismus antisemitismus und extremismus
wird dieser kampf verloren gehen und
damit auch der erste märz in
sonntagsreden
daher die flaggen bundesweit auf
halbmast senken am gedenktag ist gut
wenn sich die blicke der menschen
zusätzlich heben und alle im alltag
gesicht zeigen gegen extremismus
rassismus
und antisemitismus dann sind wir auf
einem guten weg den kampf gegen den
terror auch zu gewinnen herzlichen land
[Applaus]
gebaut und der zivilgesellschaft in
seiner rede hervor gehoben
nächste rednerin ist irene mihalic sie
ist die parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin der grünen eine der
parlamentarische geschäftsführer rennen
das wort hat die kollegin dr irene
mihalic für die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen alle
terroranschläge egal mit welchem
hintergrund haben eines gemeinsam jedes
mal sind menschen sinnlos willkürlich
und auf grausame art und weise aus ihrem
leben gerissen worden und die
hinterbliebenen trägt das für ihr ganzes
leben die politik hat genau diese
menschen jahrelang vernachlässigt das
muss und das wird sich ändern liebe
kolleginnen
in einem ersten schritt haben wir als
ampelkoalition den elften märz zum
nationalen gedenktag für die opfer
terroristischer gewalt erklärt um eben
die aufmerksamkeit auf diejenigen zu
richten die wir nicht schützen konnten
egal ob beim terror der raf des nsu oder
islamistische zellen immer wieder ist
die opferperspektive aus dem blick
geraten wir wollen aber nicht mehr nur
einseitig über die täter sprechen
sondern stärker den opfern und
hinterbliebenen zu wenden sie verdienen
unsere empathie unsere ganze solidarität
und eben auch die öffentliche
aufmerksamkeit
der umgang staatlicher stellen mit
betroffenen von terroranschlägen ließ in
der vergangenheit allzu oft die
notwendige sensibilität und
zugewandtheit vermissen ich denke hier
zum beispiel an hanau anstatt die
angehörigen in ihrer trauer aufzufangen
und zu unterstützen hat man sie in
gefährderansprachen davor gewarnt sich
für diesen anschlag an wem auch immer zu
rechnen oder auch die nächsten
angehörigen der opfer des nsu nach den
morgen haben die sicherheitsbehörden auf
basis rassistischer vorurteile ermittelt
und die täter vor allem in den
betroffenen familien gesucht dem
eigentlich nahe liegenden rechtsextremen
mögen das gibt es nicht nur ein
ukrainischer haben auch in deutsch wir
behandeln wir behandeln diese menschen
entsprechen sie an wie ungeimpfte das
heißt auch wer mit sie nowak oder mit
sputnik v oder fünf geimpft wurde wird
wie ungeimpft behandelt und zur impfung
eingeladen oder zur impfung animiert und
motiviert vielen dank die nächste frage
von herrn otto radio schleswig holstein
der erste teil ist im grunde schon
beantwortet es ging auch noch mal um die
möglichkeiten nach dem zweiten april
können sie noch einmal was dazu sagen
herr ministerpräsident was muss dann
eigentlich passieren damit sie was
entscheiden können dass wir das diesen
schritt noch einmal erklärt haben bitte
und die zweite frage noch einmal ganz
einfach und ganz kurz was erwarten sie
eigentlich morgen von der mpk 0
also ich
will darüber gar nicht ja nicht so lange
spekulieren weil das was uns das
bundesgesetz gibt werden wir in
schleswig holstein so nicht zur
anwendung bringen da muss sich keiner
zu intensiv mitte auseinander setzen
weil die regelung bedeutet die dort
festgelegt ist dass wir ein hotspot
festlegen als land not bot sollte
landkreis seine kreisfreie stadt und
dann müssten wir dem landtag einen
vorschlag machen und der landtag müsste
dann jeweils darüber beraten welcher
bereich als hotspot festgelegt ist was
für kriterien dort greifen ist im
bundesgesetz eher rudimentär beschrieben
da wird von einem starken
infektionsgeschehen gesprochen von einer
schwierigen situation in den
krankenhäusern in der entsprechenden
region aber das amerikanische volk hat
den aufruf von präsident nach leer hilfe
schwieriger werden sollte und schwierig
heißt dass wir in den krankenhäusern an
der belastungsgrenze kommen und ich
weise noch einmal darauf hin dass wir
davon extrem weit entfernt sind also ich
möchte wirklich diese sorge einfach auch
hier nicht verbreiten dass diese
situation jetzt irgendwie von uns als
bedrohlich empfunden wird aber wenn dann
machen maßnahmen aus unserer sicht nur
für das gesamte land sinn und das hat
der gesundheitsminister eben ja auch
genau erläutert wie unser krankenhaus
system aufgebaut ist dass wir uns
natürlich gegenseitig helfen und mit
sicherheit wie nie in die situation
kommen dass in einem kreis die situation
nicht mehr beherrschbar ist dann würden
wir selbstverständlich auch über unser
krankenhaus system uns gegenseitig
helfen und deswegen ist das gesetz in
dem punkt einfach aus unserer sicht
überhaupt nicht praktikabel das ist
jetzt aber so und wir sie können aber
mit der situation im moment schließlich
holstein gut umgehen
wir haben ja heute die pressekonferenz
gemacht weil ja klar ist was jetzt kommt
und die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
deswegen nicht mehr abgewartet werden
muss das gesetz ist ja jetzt durch den
gesundheitsausschuss des bundestages
durch das heißt am freitag wird das
gesetz im bundestag so beschlossen und
ich gehe auch davon aus dass es im
bundesrat dafür eine mehrheit gibt ich
glaube dass wir uns in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit anderen
fragen sehr viel intensiver beschäftigen
müssen auf haben sowohl die
finanzministerin als auch der
gesundheitsminister hingewiesen die
frage ukraine klagt erkannt wurden und
drittens opfer und ihre hinterbliebenen
dürfen nicht unmittelbar nach den
anschlägen nur mit warmen worten bedacht
werden oder sogar für symbol politische
initiativen missbraucht werden ihre
begleitung und unterstützung muss uns
ein dauerhaftes anliegen sein und zwar
von dem moment an wo das geschehen ist
was nicht hätte geschehen dürfen ganz
herzlich
das wort hat die abgeordnete beatrix von
storch für die afg fraktion
frau präsidentin meine dort präsidentin
meine damen und herren wir sprechen
heute also über die einführung des
nationalen gedenktages für die opfer des
terrorismus das ist gut denn wir mussten
zuletzt erleben dass das andenken der
terroropfer sogar mit füßen getreten
wurde wer wie bundespräsident steinmeier
die raf terroristin gudrun ensslin in
einer reihe mit hannah arendt oder
hildegard von bingen stellt verhöhnt der
raf terror opfer nein der
bundespräsident gudrun ensslin war keine
große frau der weltgeschichte sie war
eine verurteilte mörderin und um nichts
besser als die mörder vom
breitscheidplatz von hanna oder kassel
wes geistes kind muss man sein um eine
vierfache mörderin auf eine stufe mit
einer heiligen zu stellen
den europäischen gedenktag für die opfer
des terrorismus gibt es schon viel
länger am 11 märz 2004 ermordeten
islamistische terroristen in madrid 191
personen und verletzten über 2000 das
haben wir gerade gehört damals wurde der
europäische gedenktag ins leben gerufen
und 17 lange jahre später hat nun
endlich auch deutschland einen gedenk
tag es war der bundesbeauftragte kuba
der die sprachlosigkeit des staates den
opfern gegenüber
anklagen musste warum diese
sprachlosigkeit mut zur wahrheit weil
sie alle hier bis heute nicht wahrhaben
wollen dass die mit weitem abstand
größte terrorbedrohung unserer zeit vom
islamismus ausgeht ein jahr nach madrid
mit 191 toten die selbstmordanschläge in
london 52 tote über 700 verletzte 2015
paris 130 tote knapp 1000 verletzte 2016
nizza 86 tote mehr als 400 verletzt und
selbst als der islamistische terror am
breitscheidplatz in berlin zwölf
menschenleben kostete und 67 zum teil
schwer verletzt hielt die
sprachlosigkeit an und die war so
ohrenbetäubend
dass die angehörigen der opfer einen
brief an die bundeskanzlerin
schreiben mussten weil sie sich so im
stich gelassen fühlten was für ein
tiefpunkt im umgang mit den opfern
es ist gut dass wir jetzt diese
straflosigkeit hinter uns lassen und
alle opfer gedenken sie haben
unendliches leid erfahren wir gedenken
der väter und mütter der söhne und
töchter die sinnlos ermordet wurden wir
gedenken am motto politiker und
wirtschaftsführer die buback schleier
herrhausen rohwedder und walter lippe
wir müssen der opfer gedenken und den
terrorismus bekämpfen das schulden wir
den opfern die terrorgefahr bleibt real
der generalbundesanwalt hat
2021 fünf ermittlungsverfahren gegen
rechtsextremismus und rechts terroristen
eröffnet 10 gegen linksterroristen und
234 für gegen islamistische terroristen
die taten unterscheiden sich signifikant
in der zahl nicht in ihrer menschen
achten ob raf oder antiimperialistische
zellen und nsu oder combat 18 ob
islamischer staat oder die hisbollah
oder die vielen einzeltäter terroristen
sind niemals
freiheitskämpfer oder märtyrer sie sind
einfach nur verbrecher und mörder
allesamt dieser gedenkt
erinnert
an ihre opfer und daran dass das oberste
ziel unseres staates ist menschen zu
schützen und das braucht mut zur
wahrheit vielen dank
wer trotz wichtig war dass die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der afg und für die kurzen technischen
probleme die es hier bei der übertragung
gab möchte ich mich hier noch einmal
entschuldigen
nächster redner ist bach pascal kober
erst der beauftragte der bundesregierung
für die anliegen von betroffenen von
terroristischen losen extremistischen
anschlägen im inland und er ist auch
mitglied des deutschen bundestags
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
am vergangenen freitag haben wir in
deutschland zum ersten mal den
nationalen gedenktag für die opfer
terroristischer gewalt gegangen
auf diesen tag auf dieses gedenken haben
viele betroffene lange gewartet
und viele von ihnen haben sich auch ganz
persönlich und mit nachdruck dafür
eingesetzt dass es einen solchen
gedenktag auch in unserem land gibt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
nicht selbstverständlich
nach den tiefen verwundungen die ein
solcher terroristischer anschlag einem
körper mit einer seele zufügt die kraft
zu finden neben der sorge um sich selbst
und seine angehörigen neben der trauer
sich auch noch für verbesserungen in der
opferbetreuung im opferschutz oder eben
für ein würdiges gedenken einzusetzen
und viele der betroffenen tun dies seit
vielen jahren und sie werden es auch in
zukunft weiterhin mit viel kraft und
unermüdlich tun und ich möchte mich bei
ihnen für ihren einsatz sehr herzlich
bedanken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
ein gutes zeichen dass wir den gedenktag
für die opfer von terror nun auch in
deutschland eingeführt haben und daher
möchte ich mich auch bedanken bei den
koalitionsfraktionen die diesen tag in
den koalitionsvertrag hineingeschrieben
und gefordert haben und ich möchte mich
bei der bundesregierung bedanken dass
sie ihn schon in diesem jahr angepackt
und umgesetzt hat
mit diesem gedenktag haben wir nun auch
in deutschland einen öffentlichen raum
geschaffen der es unserem ganzen land
ermöglicht innezuhalten
anteil zu nehmen am schicksal der
betroffenen
ein raum wurde geschaffen der stilles
nachdenkliches aber auch klagen dass
vielleicht auch an klagen das gedenken
erlaubt einen raum der für opfer die
worte des trostes und der solidarität
ermöglicht und dafür einen würdigen
rahmen eröffnet
am vergangenen freitag haben wir diesen
gedenktag erstmalig in deutschland
begangen mit reden von bundesministerin
nancy faeser für die bundesregierung mit
worten vom präsidenten des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes stefan haber
dass repräsentanten eines der obersten
verfassungsorgane und mir selbst
beauftragten der bundesregierung für die
anliegen von betroffenen von
terroristischer und extremistischer
gewalt im inland manche haben gefragt wo
dabei die stimme der betroffenen
geblieben ist
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen aufgrund
der kürze der zeit es waren nur drei
wochen vom beschluss des kabinetts ist
zur umsetzung und aufgrund der pandemie
situation wurde diese idee der
beteiligung der opferperspektive
durch die worte von frau professor petra
t rufen umgesetzt die wissenschaftlich
über die rolle von opfern
terroristischer gewalt die modernen
gesellschaft forscht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dieser
erste gedenktages in seiner umsetzung
noch ein weiter zu gestaltendes und
weiterzuentwickeln das format das wir
gemeinsam unter beteiligung der
betroffenen weiter entwickeln wollen und
weiter entwickeln werden diese
zusicherung hierfür habe ich auch von
seiten der bundesregierung und aus der
mitte des deutschen bundestages an die
betroffenen übermitteln können dafür
auch noch einmal herzlicher dank
die weko ihren kollegen es gibt unter
den opfern bei dem jene die eine aktive
beteiligung wünschen und jene für die an
diesem gedenktag das mitgefühl und die
solidarität der gesellschaft mit ihnen
im mittelpunkt gesehen wird wichtig
sollte uns aber allen sein dass von
diesem tag eines ausgeht wir vergessen
sie liebe sehr verehrte betroffene von
terroristischer gewalt nicht sie sie
wurden persönlich getroffen aber
stellvertretend für unsere ganze
gesellschaft wir fühlen uns mit
getroffen weil wir alle von den tätern
mit gemeint sind wir wollen an ihrer
seite stehen nicht nur nach einem
anschlag sondern dauerhaft und
verlässlich
und ich möchte sie im deutschen
bundestag danken ihnen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen dass sie diesem gedenktag
auch hier im haus heute einen raum
gegeben haben herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin martina renner
für die fraktion die linke martina
renner ist innenpolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen der
demokratischen fraktionen der 23 februar
dieses jahres er war für rené salzmann
ein bewegender tag sie war aus israel
nach frankfurt am main gekommen um an
ihre tante blancas mikro zu erinnern die
am 23
februar 1992 durch einen schwedischen
rechts terroristen auf offener straße
ermordet wurde
26 jahre hatte es bis zu seiner
verurteilung gedauert obwohl er kurz
nach der tat bereits verdächtig war
30 jahre hat es gedauert bis die stadt
frankfurt am ort des attentates eine
gedenktafel errichtet
der anstoß er kam aus der engagierten
zivilgesellschaft über eine erfolgreiche
petition von guten geschäft
warum erzähle ich dies
diese geschichte zeigt für mich
erinnerung ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit
erinnerung ist ein aktiver
aneignung und das weitererzählen der
geschichte der opfer
will der nationale gedenktag für die
opfer des terrorismus kein anlass für
ein passives oder gar ritualisiert des
gedenkens sein oder werden dann muss er
zuerst nicht die institutionen die
beauftragten die offiziellen bühne
sondern mit den betroffenen gemeinsam
eine würdige form und einen inhalt
finden der deren trauer aber auch deren
anliegen raum gibt die
schmale
konsequent währung
das protokoll für diesen tag in die
hände der opfer zu legen die vertreter
und vertreterinnen des status der
behörden der politik sie sollten lieber
diesen tag zum anlass nehmen sich die
frage zu stellen warum zuständige in den
sicherheitsbehörden terror nicht
verhindert haben
warum die bekämpfung des terrorismus zum
spielball jeweiliger politischer
interessen gemacht unser profilierung
genutzt wurde
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das meine
ich damit was meine ich mit dieser
profilierung auf jeden anschlag
folgten bisher routiniert die forderung
nach mehr überwachung und
gesetzesverschärfung aber das konkrete
handeln der ermittlungsbehörden im
vorfeld und der justiz im nachgang wie
es die um die es heute geht ließ die
angehörigen und verletzten auf ratlos
bis wütend zurück ob nsu
breitscheidplatz oder hanno
man hat den eindruck dem schließen der
akten galt mehr energie als dem
ausleuchten der netzwerke und
untersuchungsausschüsse waren für einige
in den behörden ganz offensichtlich und
spürbar stören zu bieten
ansprüche und forderungen der
angehörigen wurden allzu oft abgewehrt
und nicht aktiv beantwortet der
bundesverband für die beratungsprojekte
zu diesem thema begrüßt wie auch nicht
das klare signal dass mit der
entscheidung der bundesregierung für
diesen gedenktag gesetzt wurde
erforderlich ist jetzt ein in der praxis
verbesserte opferschutz aber auch
erfolgreiche präventionsarbeit gut
effektive strafverfolgung und aufklärung
von wo es zwischen taten
erfolgen auch abschiebeschutz für opfer
rechter und rassistischer gewalt und
terror wie in den schlussfolgerungen der
nsu untersuchungsausschüsse gefordert
eingangs sprach ich von der
notwendigkeit aktiv erinnerungen sie ist
auch die rückhaltlose aufklärung und
schutz aller von terror bedrohten
endlich realität werden zu lassen vielen
dank
martina wenders rede war das für die
linksfraktion und die nächste rednerin
elisabeth kaiser von der spd fraktion
ist auch mitglied in der
fraktionsarbeitsgruppe strategien gegen
rechtsextremismus
beschäftigt sich also auch mit den
opfern rechtsextremistischer
gewalt das wetter der kollege uli
goltsch für die spd und jetzt ist doch
noch ein anderer redner hier
reingekommen und die grätsche spricht
für die spd-fraktion
sident den liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
wir haben im koalitionsvertrag den
gedenktag für die opfer terroristische
gewalt vereinbart und es spricht für
eine hoch verantwortungsbewusste und
auch sehr empathische art politik zu
machen dass sie frau bundesministerin
dieses vorhaben so prioritär umgesetzt
haben so dass wir dieses jahr schon am
11 märz sinke denkt tag begehen können
dafür auch an dieser stelle nochmals
vielen dank
warum es so wichtig war diesen gedenktag
einzuführen und wieso es so wertvoll ist
dass es so zügig eingeführt wurde ich
würde es ihnen sagen weil wir nicht
wollen dass terroropfer nur eine zahl
sind weil wir nicht wollen dass über
täter mehr gesprochen wird als über die
opfer und ihre angehörigen und weil wir
nicht wollen dass ihre namen nur
irgendwann in den geschichtsbüchern
erwähnung finden weil wir es die
ministerin als gesagt den angehörigen
schuldig sind weil wir an einem solchen
gedenkt demokratie feinden zeigen dass
wir mehr sind dass wir solidarisch sind
dass wir unsere werte verteidigen mit
allem was wir haben
auch
auf der seite des
bundesinnenministeriums heißt es über
gedenktage durch sie werden kollektiv
erlebte schlüssel ereignisse oder
erfahrungen als für die gegenwart
bedeutsam und erinnerungswürdig
hervorgerufen zitat ende und ich glaube
dieser satz trifft es ganz exakt um was
es geht wenn man sich die liste unserer
gedenktage nämlich ansieht dann ist es
eine art zusammenfassung
jüngere deutsche geschichte meilensteine
unserer vergangenheit wenn man so möchte
negative natürlich aber auch positive
sie mahnen uns uns zu erinnern sie sind
auftrag für alle kommenden generationen
sichern unser selbstverständnis an
unsere staatsraison zu ändern unsere
erinnerungskultur ist staatsräson und
dennoch wird sie seit einiger zeit immer
wieder in frage gestellt unsere
geschichte unsere vergangenheit wird
relativiert und sogar angedeutet das
stichwort corona diktatur das ist der
beweis dafür dass wir brauchen genau
deshalb sind gedenktage weiterhin
wichtig sie mahnen uns eben niemals zu
vergessen indem wir durch gedenktage
unser kollektives gedächtnis
regelmäßig aufrütteln und auffrischen
vielen dank
damit kommen wir zum vorletzten redner
in dieser vereinbarten debatte also zu
einer tagesaktuellen
politischen debatte zu der sich die
fraktionen
gemeinsam geeinigt haben diese hier
abzuhalten das ist volker ullrich für
die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren die richtung eines
nationalen gedenktages für die opfer
terroristischer gewalt ist eine richtige
entscheidung und ein kraftvolles zeichen
der empathie und des mitgefühls
wir müssen nicht nur an die opfer
terroristischer taten denken
sondern die zertrümmerte welt auch aus
ihren augen sehen und uns fragen was hat
denn diese terrortat mit den opfern und
ihren angehörigen gemacht und hat der
staat genügend getan um sie zu schützen
oder sie im nachhinein nach der tat
genügende hinreichend betreut
ich durfte in zwei
untersuchungsausschüssen in diesem haus
mitglied sein zu einem nsu 2 und zum
anderen im untersuchungsausschuss für
bei dem bezug auf den anschlag am
breitscheidplatz und
zu den bedrückendsten
begegnungen gehört der zusammenkunft der
ausschussmitglieder mit den opfern und
ihren angehörigen
nach der debatte hier im plenum und
die angehörige opfer haben uns gesagt
dass sie sich vom staat komplett im
stich gelassen haben gefühlt
eine angehörige eines opfers
hat als allererstes eine rechnung von
der pathologie bekommen
anderen mussten wochenlang auf termine
warten bei der traumaambulanz
und uns entgegen gehalten worden der
staat hat versagt uns und unsere
liebsten zu schützen und er hat ein
zweites mal versagt bei der betreuung
unserer schmerzes und
unserer lebenslage und deswegen muss von
diesem gedenktag
das wichtige signal ausgehen dass der
staat gelernt hat und dass er die opfer
niemals alleine lassen dass
die verbesserungen im opferschutz
sollte keine frage
parteipolitische debatten sein sondern
eines klugen handelns und einer
entschlossenen politik
es ist gut dass der deutsche bundestag
in der letzten wahlperiode eine reform
der sozialen entschädigungsrecht auf den
weg gebracht hat
es wird erst 2024 gänzlich in kraft
treten aber viele wichtige regelungen
sind vorgezogen worden nicht nur die
frage der härte fahrleistungen sondern
auch alle regelungen in bezug auf die
psychologische betreuung weil das was
angehörige von terroropfern brauchen ist
auch eine richtige betreuung dass sie
der staat an der hand nimmt dass sie
ihren schmerz auch überwinden können das
sind wir ganz konkret den angehörigen
schuldig
wir müssen uns aber auch weiterhin auf
den weg machen die wesentlichen fragen
zu beantworten die sich rund um
terroristische bedrohungen stellen wir
müssen noch besser werden bei der frage
der prävention und der der
radikalisierung
kein mensch wird als terrorist es
rechtsextremer als antisemit geboren
menschen werden dass
die frage ist warum menschen dazu werden
was der staat tun kann und präventiv
tätig zu werden wir müssen weiterhin
unsere sicherheitsbehörden im blick
haben und sie stärken bei der frage der
befugnisse und der ermittlung aber auch
in der ganz konkreten
konfliktsituation nach einem
terroristischen angriff es ist für
keinen rettungssanitäter und verteiler
polizeibeamten leicht auch mit den
opfern umzugehen schlimme nachrichten zu
überbringen auch hier haben polizei und
rettungskräfte unsere solidarität
verdient
und das ist mein letzter gedanke wir
müssen auch die opferverbände stärken
die sich in selbsthilfe zusammentun und
ich bin auch den neuen opfer
beauftragten dankbar dass er mit großer
empathie heute vorgetragen hat und
lassen sie uns die angelegenheiten des
opferschutzes in diesem haus gemeinsam
debattieren weil es geht ja um die
selbstverteidigung des staates nicht nur
gegen terroristische bedrohung so es
geht auch um die bewahrung und inhalt
der höhere der opfer darum dass ihr
andenken gehört wird und dass der staat
auch aus diesen taten lernt um wie ich
eingangs sagte mit den augen der
betroffenen diese taten zu sehen
herzlichen dank
volker ullrich war das für die cdu/csu
hat ja von seinen erfahrungen in den
untersuchungsausschüssen auch gesprochen
und wir kommen zur letzten rednerin in
dieser vereinbarten die zweite das ist
die schon von mir angekündigte elisabeth
kaiser aus der spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
überlebende und angehörige
letzte woche beginnen wir zum ersten mal
den nationalen gedenktag für die opfer
terroristischer gewalt dieses erinnern
ist nicht nur ein besonderes anliegen
unserer bundesinnenministerium nancy
faeser und der koalition der elfter märz
steht für eine neue innenpolitik denn
damit erhalten die toten und ihre
familien die verletzten und
traumatisierten von anschlägen und
morden die ihnen gebührende
aufmerksamkeit
zusammenhalt bedeutet die überlebenden
und angehörigen in unsere mitte zu
nehmen und eine klare botschaft zu
senden wir zusammen sind stärker als
terror und hass
[Applaus]
warum
warum ist das so wichtig weil leider zu
oft und so spät gesehen haben was
passiert wenn tote oder angehörige
selbst zu verdächtigen gemacht wurden so
wie nach dem neunten september 2000 als
der blumenhändler in der schirn check in
nürnberg wo nationalsozialistischen
untergrund als erstes opfer der mord
serie brutal erschossen wurde und man
bei den ermittlungen über jahre daran
festhielt dass ein drogenkurier gewesen
sei beispiele wie diese sind so
zahlreich
sie dürfen sich nicht wiederholen
es gilt die angehörigen zu wort kommen
zu lassen und ihnen zuzuhören
politisches und persönliches gedenken
sind zwei seiten einer medaille
nur zusammen ist dies mahnung und
würdigung zugleich
dafür steht nun symbolisch der gedenk
tag des elften märz es gilt die
überlebenden und hinterbliebenen
die konkrete politische aufarbeitung und
erinnerungsarbeit einzubeziehen denn
auch nach den verheerenden
dschihadistischen anschlag auf dem
berliner breitscheidplatz leben sie bei
der gedenkstätten planung außen vor und
ich bin daher sehr dankbar dass die
bundesregierung nun auch die betroffenen
und ihre position deutlich stärken wird
die ausweitung der unterstützungsarbeit
durch die koordinierungsstelle für die
nachsorge opfer und angehörigen hilfe
ist dafür ein sehr wichtiger schritt ein
würdiges gedenken bedeutet auch weitere
terroristische und insbesondere
rechtsextreme anschläge zu verhindern um
die sicherheit aller die dieses land ihr
zuhause und zu umfassend zu schützen und
zu gewährleisten umso notwendiger ist es
dass nun der gestern vorgestellte
aktionsplan gegen rechtsextremismus in
die umsetzung kommt damit aus worten
keine weiteren taten werden und die
sensibilität für die angehörigen der
opfer und die opferperspektive bei den
ermittlungen eben auch berücksichtigt
werden in diesem sinne möchte ich in
überlegungen und angehörigen der toten
anna terroranschläge versichern wir
stehen fest an ihrer seite vielen dank
das war hier die vereinbarte debatte zur
einführung eines nationalen gedenktages
für die opfer terroristischer gewalt am
11 märz er wurde ja hier schon einmal in
deutschland begangen in der eu wird
bereits seit 2005 an die opfer von
terroristischer gewalt an diesem tag
erinnert und wir beenden damit auch
unsere online übertragung aus dem
deutschen bundestag ab morgen sind wir
natürlich wieder auch im linearen
fernsehen hier dabei aber wenn es um 9
uhr los geht mit einer videoansprache
des präsidenten der ukraine wolodimir
selensky und dann wird es auch um die
energieversorgung in deutschland gehen
um die impfpflicht und natürlich auch um
die lage der ukrainischen flüchtlinge
und um die ukraine krise
damit verabschieden wir uns hier aus dem
deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
heute wäre eine gute gelegenheit sich
für starke kommunen in unserem land
einzusetzen und das sage ich als
haushälter bewusst ist kostet noch nicht
mal geld sondern wir bräuchten lediglich
die zustimmung zu diesem antrag denn